hi everybody
I'm taking it over to the show right now
we did press and it took a long time
right now we did press and it took a
long time and also I'm hungry so if any
all have food I'd appreciate it ah yo
what up so look here's here's my badge
going to the show right now man that
user done some how do i how do i
permanently hide you even better
perfect big time CES coma takeover it's
true it's true so you know y'all gonna
y'all gotta wait while we while we get
to the show your streams is so funny
thank you oh yeah yeah yeah we're we're
launching the Hyundai harness yeah
that's that's a product announcement
yeah we're making an announcement it's
gonna take some time it's not a
self-driving over no no it's not no you
didn't miss anything don't worry you
ever watch The Bachelor hey Virgil
Icarus never watch The Bachelor where
you gotta like wait through seven
commercial breaks before they tell you
who they're giving the final rose to
we're gonna make this like that
so we're gonna wait for the people to
show up over wearing my my comma
jumpsuit right now see yes is the
Consumer Electronics Show is the largest
the largest trade show in the world and
[Music]
I'm here right now on location in Vegas
and we wait for some people to show up
what's up Larry a role player comma
jumpsuit does anyone want to buy one of
these I'll sell you mine it's mine
personally they give them to the company
I'll sell you my person
what's up yes I heard Sony made a card
no open pilots a boy it's not allowed
you purchased the Kama jumpsuit yeah
well we'll look into that we'll look
into that
no I'm not signing anything yo I'm
really hungry or if you guys got pizza I
really I really want some pizza
if we're announcing a camera extension
or a micro sized yawn hmm you can buy my
t-shirt right now go to comment on AI
this Burger King y'all I'll settle for a
burger you got tender-crisp that'd be
great
um but no mail on that tender crisp
spicy tender crisp Cotto
there was a spoiler it's not time yet
for Carver and I think when I win a Ford
Flex right no hope I'll support you
yeah full self-driving yet I thought
yeah that's guys it's not real test the
lie to you yeah bobland I'm gonna feel
you um yeah not full-sized rap he's not
real Johnny Stein welcome welcome to the
first time stream bro no but you're
gonna you're gonna come with me right
now well we went make our way to the
comma booth and Tesla didn't lie they
exaggerated you know they stretched the
truth full self-driving won't be real
for quite a while but we have an
incredible announcement planned for you
today I didn't put any steel balls to
try to throw through the new product
unfortunately what time right I lied are
you guys are gonna really Tesla stretch
that your full self driving is not
coming anytime soon
I look tired yeah I'm doing press all
morning it's called market again we
don't do that
dude can't believe commas fine oh yeah
there's new product oh well you guys
don't know there's a new product what
are we here for
want to think about the ps5 and wheels I
saw the logo I don't know if anything
else was announced yeah open palette is
quite good right [ __ ] vapor will know
this product is real and I'll tell you
this right I'll do a leak right now I'll
let you guys know that you'll be able to
purchase this product literally as soon
as this live stream is over
cool yeah jump out right here thank you
very much have a good day yes I'm in an
uber right now uh welcome to CES good
thing I remembered my badge George Hotz
I present no we don't have any events in
South Florida I'm sorry all right
we're heading in right now all right
I'm not sure I'm allowed to livestream
in there so I'm keeping you guys on the
DL no I'm gonna I'm gonna bring you guys
in just just be stealthy like right I
promise you it's not a connector
thank you all right we're just we just
got by security
I could put you guys in my pocket if we
need to but I don't think we need to
oh is this a line no it can't be it
can't be all right we're going in but
going in I'm gonna flip you around oh
yeah we're going in all right
live from the CES showroom floor I'm
glad you love the Subaru harness we're
announcing that car no no no we're in
wearing we're in
oh no you're gonna have to wait for the
news all right what do we got is it
quality good I've got a good stream
going y'all cooking it up in a crock-pot
Tyler thank you welcome welcome to the
live stream haha good we're in
autonomous drives generation next
generation millimeter wave radar guys yo
okay quality that's good this is not
shot on a lake oh look 403 um now I'm a
little sick that's why all attire - are
we lost
where's our booth that
oh yeah IOT infrastructure oh yeah
yo yo alright everybody hide the new
product stand in front of it don't let
anybody see the new product yet stand in
front of it welcome to the Khmer icees
booth I'm glad to have you all here with
us oh yo on the press demo this morning
the only disengagement there was an
accident right in front of us
yeah like this car swerved across two
lanes so I disengaged for safety
definitely not caused by Karma alright
welcome what time is it oh it's 58 oh we
gotta at least make them wait does our
neighbors own say oh yeah
we good to put the website line all
right
well but we'll get will give the word
what your biggest fan you want to be on
the live stream
hi I'm George nice to meet you hi George
yes yeah the whole audience here we got
317 people live right here right now in
the common pool we got that PVC from the
highest quality strip club in Vegas oh
wait okay they can't see that that would
be the product oh that would be oh oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa well that was
close that was close
combo lasers come a phone does everyone
want to introduce themselves
all right so um we're gonna let you know
who gets the Rose we're just gonna make
everybody wait like five minutes let's
let's let's launch their product no no
we can't and 352 virtual viewers on
blocking the mic uh sound okay
the audio is weird when I flip the phone
flip the front cam otherwise audio is
low oh I see okay what the front cam
we're right here in the comic ICS booth
I've seen Logan Paul do this shot before
no Harold is driving the Prius right now
4 p.m. yeah we're gonna oh man yeah
don't don't let him don't let him don't
let him to see anything oh yourself you
know Alex let's go let's go
oh it's 1 o'clock no I'm not a coke I
did take two day cool this morning
though well well we don't talk about
that yeah yeah
yo what kind of video is this no it's
true I don't drink caffeine anymore I'm
off drugs guys I'm off drugs clean 20 20
shut out to our users
yeah this is a Hubble smear video it's a
nice video yeah showing off your videos
403 watching 409 whoa and toenails how
did you how did you see the name of the
product did you see the name of the
product right here yo check them out
check them out the name is revealed
it is the comma to
and we got boxes there's a lot of them
and we still get a little bit of time
we're gonna do the real unveiling of the
product we just got away for a few more
people to get in here we got to get to
at least 420 that's right we need more
people than Tesla's share price come on
let's go let's go , - the video came out
before the livestream announced defconn
is on the store guys
everything you see here today is live
right away
it's shipping on the 20th so if you like
what you see get your credit card out
right now get your credit card out right
now see this your credit card out right
now oh I leaked the number nope Amex is
the number on the back no it does don't
worry all right all right maybe we can
slowly start trickling things out oh no
that's that's too much that's that's not
trickling yeah yeah you have you guys
seen this here's a harness
alright 4:30 are we still getting people
though we got away we got away is the
website live but is a live website live
Oh
do it do it wait wait it's live dollars
Oh people are slamming it is it going
down slow to load alright guys if the
websites live this is the comma to check
it out truly beautiful hardware remember
some of you we reached out to why we
asked a bunch of times if you were
making the EON what would you make and
that is exactly what we've done here
with the camuto so Paul we already sold
one yo that was so fast this one's up
right here
okay so what phone it's a custom phone
I mean it's custom phone because it
doesn't have a battery it has an
infrared camera it has a custom fan
cooling solution that you're never gonna
hear and it has driver monitoring 24/7
with the infrared cameras right here
it's based on a l'école X 720
but uh-oh just ordered this is it's 999
dollars this is the comma - it comes in
a beautiful box so these boxes have real
foamies in them yes let's open a box up
let's let's put let's put a comma - here
wait what's wrong with that one you
brought the broken phones oh good we
good we good we good we good but oh yeah
let's just let's well hopefully the
camera around the comet ooh
oh this is backwards the foams and
backwards lift it out it's gonna go flip
it around don't worry all the common
tools will be packed properly yo look at
this we got we got a bit of an audience
here for really commas most consumer
friendly product yet
welcome to the fleet we have a beautiful
grab your phone to get started ah it
doesn't need a speaker we figured out
how to make the sounds mad loud the
comma 2 is really designed for acoustics
check it out
in the bottom you'll find a harness it's
the same harness oh yeah
the pandas built-in I almost forgot to
tell you this is an ODBC connector so
that will just plug right into your car
you don't need anything else all you
need is a comma to and a car harness so
this car harness just use an ODB to see
cable process is the same Snapdragon 820
one it's compatible to Aeon software but
you get driver monitoring 24/7 yeah it's
running on file 0.7 release here are
supported cars same ones as before oh no
oh no not the same GoPro mount do we
have a mount
we don't have mount let's get a mount oh
yeah we redid the mount to of course do
you think we'd leave that crappy GoPro
mount we invented the double-wide GoPro
the comment you will not comment uses
way less power because it doesn't have
to charge the battery constantly these
are the mounts custom cut VHB we
invented the double wide go problem yeah
if they already have a harness you can
just buy it you don't have to buy
another harness what you can tell them
what you want on your sold 5 y'all wow
this is a lot can you sell your black
panda not to us yeah you can sell it
short same comma power so if you buy a
harness it comes all in this one
beautiful box this box is what's gonna
show up on your doorstep ha IR LEDs dual
IR LEDs
camera in here you know the you know
board you guys been hyped about in here
is an you know it's a Snapdragon 820 one
face ID built in four DM it does not
have a face ID I'm not sure what that
would do but it has a camera right here
and that's for place we replace the one
that's usually in the phone with an
infrared camera Uno is the panda that's
integrated into the comet Oh what is the
uno so it's the built in panda so you no
longer need a panda the install in the
car is completely stealth no more stuff
on your windshield oh did I not tell you
this has a built-in high-precision GPS
in fact inside let me just pull this off
inside of this antenna of this mount
you'll find a GPS antenna built in this
has the same high-precision GPS as a
grey panda and a black panda all built
in is there a wire lens it's slightly
wider I think it's a few degrees wider
we have no problems seeing you bought
yours a month ago
pandas are now extinct yeah tear down
and reveal I mean you'll have to buy one
panda Eon GPS all built into the comet
to the case is made of ABS if you have
weird windshield angles it should be
fine I mean guys it's the eon but good
oona will not be open-source seven years
early will get years early absolutely
same harnesses
and it's just that same ODBC connector
you're just gonna need one wire and it
plugs in right there you can also use
that as a USB to connect to the phone
no you won't have to take the common two
out of your car on hot days the comma
two can withstand up to 85 degrees
Celsius we tested it we put it in an
oven it'll withstand any heat your car
has to throw at it and that's because it
has no battery in fact the battery has
been replaced by a thermal pad given the
common to unprecedented thermals oh we
didn't we should have brought a few that
were kind of in oh yeah yeah um if you
have an outstanding Ian order just email
support we'll cancel that for you
because you know you want that comment -
oh the power of an Australian summer
does not get up to 85 degrees Celsius
that's very hot they can probably do
more than 85 as well
yeah that's what the rating is on the
comment Oh typical for consumer
electronics all right that took a lot of
out of me and webbing it yeah it took a
lot
oh we have beautiful pictures yeah well
okay we're zooming out on the booth you
can see the full booth now it's almost
the same price it's 999 dollars for the
comet ooh oh and what we didn't tell you
is that the comet 2 includes three free
months of comma Prime every comma two is
gonna ship with a SIM card reactivate it
if you buy it in the US and you just
need to go in the app and you get three
free months of comma Prime we've updated
the software so the the drives upload in
real time using comma Prime
you'll be able to get updates using that
free comma Prime for three months so if
you purchase a neon two weeks ago yeah
absolutely we have a 30-day return
policy so if you have a neon that you
bought in the last 30 days you're
welcome to send it back lane changes
coming in the next release boot times
about the same as an eon but you don't
really need to turn it off no battery no
power draw it's pretty low and we're
gonna work on bringing the the power
draw while the car is off down even more
there will not be a raspberry pie for
version just a weak little thing this
opie drive better with the new Aeon
there's some things that are better
about it
so the thermals are a lot better on it
your CPUs a lot less likely to trip the
throttle out you still need the obd2
connection but that just uses the power
which connects to the Panda same cameras
except IR so you guys can do D em at
night um
boot time is all the software question
we can bring down boot time and power
draw down with software updates and we
will continue to do that we're at booth
25 20 can I show you a boot show you my
shoe no never mind I can't have their
own camera selected Ricardo give
anything dad
fundation side
at night
oh wait you guys know it's they say you
can't hear you guys can't hear anyone
for George yeah yeah maybe yeah they can
only hear this yeah
so big improvements I mean George
already went through it but plant is
included so no more fun at sticking out
of the product just one why are going
inside stock camera the other freebies
dragomir tonight there is being shown in
the video so that the money talk 24/7
and bigger Mound GoPro it's great yeah
you you you really want it you should
buy one okay I was saying that we said
you guys annoying emails asking what
what did you want why did you stop using
this product and then you answered and
then really all right how can we make
this with all of the things that they
asked and that's what we did check out
the website if you haven't a brand new
website
it gets really beautiful
oh yeah and you can buy it with a firm I
know I said I'd never do that but we're
selling out cuz we got to make money
how what was the last without direct
power no time at all doesn't have a
battery is there a way to invest sadly
now we're a private company a wide-angle
camera same angle in fact you know we're
not even using the full angle of the
camera in the model so we'll get there
it's so as the harness but again
everything goes either under the trim or
is the device it's just one wire it's
the same harness so if you already have
a harness you can just use the harness
won't harm the screen not really yeah
look at the beautiful video right remote
Java position we have no Java and we
have no remote we are hiring it's true
if you want to be hired for machine
learning to the programming challenge if
you want to be hired by open PI out
submit for words no pork West Alton
power focused on power yeah so we're
gonna get hired well you can always you
the program challenge stuff no the Black
Panthers will continue to be on sale you
can upgrade your young with a black pant
at any time how many drivers are
currently on the road we have but a
thousand daily active is about 1500
monthly actives will it work on GM
absolutely do you need a siesta gree to
get hired I don't care who knows the new
boy dad is it on - yeah yeah
do you have an yan what's the USP driver
monitoring at night big mound quiet fan
it's just better
oh yeah leave it on your windshield no
battery what if you don't already have a
harness $200 you can buy a harness perm
install what phone it's the same phone
it's a it's the same way you go
appropriate no flex Rea leaving me
unplugged in battery drain is better
with the new product and we're gonna
work to drive it down even further so
because there's no batteries so we're
directly driving the battery circuit in
the phone which means you don't have to
go through the next step of conversion
so it's a bit more efficient when we're
talking about it last night we can even
get it down even more so yeah the
comments who's gonna draw considerably
last Venna neon if you're just out of 30
days 30 days is our policy upgrade kit
no upgrade kit pacific batteries trash
yeah look yeah yeah driver monitoring at
night the old yun will continue to be
supported through probably just shy of
open pilot 1.0
you fixed everything that was not nice
with the old yeah very nice product
thank you thank you we try
when's the press release going out we
did some press this morning and write a
medium post I was lazy shy write a
medium post come a watt I don't know
what the comma watt is Robert you have
anything you want to add that's it yeah
that's it that's all your problem that's
it that's the new product I don't know I
mean these we've still got a lot of
people here we got to keep the
livestream going how many of you sold
all I have been Oh Evan that's a lot
we're rich what you miss around driver
monitoring it's 24/7 unique selling
point I got you it's 24/7 driver
monitoring works all the time
can you just run an external power
source without the ODB it's pretty clean
but if you really don't want to run it
yeah though you actually know it also
connects to the can down there - yeah
in-depth QA check out the new website
you know we've answered a lot of
questions on the website I'm gonna put
you right here hopefully you guys can
hear me driver monitoring isn't a
selling point it is because the
alternative is we lag how many can we
sell so the first 300 ship on the 20th
of January so if you buy within the
first 300 your 20th of January later
than that it's first-come first-serve
we're gonna build them out slow what is
key is supported yeah we support care
oh look I'm delicious of 30 cars were
Kia bro you know what that says this is
Kia CI artwork through sunglasses no it
can't see your eyes if you're wearing
sunglasses at night it will but I don't
know why you're wearing sunglasses at
night um so I don't know how to help you
with that
there better be an Outback I'm not less
yeah we'll get the Outback yet DM works
kind of fine with sunglasses it
shouldn't bother you
yes but the battery was only a net
negative on your power no you don't have
to weigh that you under both the Aeon
stays on if you haven't driven your car
within 30 hours you have to wait for it
to boot but it has the same technology
as the black panda so it's not like you
have to restart your car ever you're
never going to see any warning lights on
your dashboard all you need is a common
two and a car harness 1199 total when
will comma 3 get released you know every
year bro it's every year bro oh where
maybe every two years I'll probably keep
next year we'll do like the comma to
slim you know what it was what do they
all do please continue to say awesome
always try thank you thank you
ah well I visit AI emoto's booth here
maybe we'll do some live streaming we
visit people's boots I are only on and
not yes you have plenty of light during
the day you the cover to the harness and
power the powers included with the
harness so if you're just by a comma -
and a harness it's called the combi -
dev kit
why was the old battery never removed
from the old deal and you had to wait
for the new product by a comma to
you can't sell just the case the phone
is completely reworked we have a custom
Flex PCB inside the phone replacing the
battery we replace the camera with an IR
camera yeah the camera IG's yeah that's
right that's why I get the Abba
reference graphics and sounds yeah how
are sales go how many we sell so still
eleven shop link on Twitter merch
Lincoln bio oh yeah no one's bought with
a firm yet if the comma - dies I'm
leaving it out in the Sun is there any
kind of warranty so we have a one-year
warranty on the device so yeah if it it
shouldn't break from leaving in the Sun
yeah we'll fix it
ships January 20th
we got we got a firm order we got our
first two firm order that makes 12
you knew you made the right move by
waiting some time waiting pays off this
is gonna be around for a long time this
is really 1.0 hardware can we use driver
motoring all the time you can change it
to do that how many users nowadays it's
like a thousand dailies 1500 monthlies
features come to give a coupon Oh get
out of here with your coupon features of
the Camuto
we got a big mount check it out it's a
big solid mount we got ODBC with an
integrated panda
we got IR LEDs and an IR camera
the driver monitor at night you guys can
see one on one it's on runs the same
software what feature would make one put
another hardware I think this is 1.0
hardware the software is gonna need a
bit more work how long will you gonna be
supported yeah we'll see see if it gets
annoying I mean you know it's all
hardware right what will phase them out
gradually but you know we are consumer
electronics company this is what we do I
am sitting on the floor yeah even though
I have an installment Union you did
purchase become a prime so how do i
repair the new comma - i'll know what
that means steering mods I mean we
didn't release any steering rods but
check this cord bro how does upgrading
work for 30 day policy that's from what
is it from the day you from the day you
received it so from the day you received
it you have 30 days to return it YouTube
thinks of the combitube videos targets
were children excellent we love making
child-friendly content here at comm a I
this is a Christian Channel
you can have one of these one of these
can be yours if you pick one up in
person no we're not doing in person that
allowed to sell things here he and Nero
go to just comment at AI and you can
check how to update the common to do new
version automatic updates over Wi-Fi or
if you have common prime of course comma
Prime
no trading program planned
Andrew hints thank you thank you it's
it's really pleasant to just leave it in
the car
what's the biggest point behind no
battery because the batteries are
terrible and get puffy is
right-hand-drive supported that's all a
software problem yep it will be all
engineering is these work these were
designed and manufactured in California
that's America for fur fur for people
watching like that that's America why
did you spend $4 in black pant I mean
you have a black pant it's a great
product remember also that you it's 200
G per on your comet too because you
don't need to buy a harness you can
reuse the same artist that you have with
your black panda we wanted to offer an
upgrade path for eons but then we add
all these sick features to the comet oh
so you're gonna want it you can use the
black man for something else absolutely
you use whatever you want
ah what's the second best feature on the
comet - over the year on the driver
monitoring the driver monitoring 24/7 if
you're afraid you might fall asleep at
night get a comet oh because they're
trying to make money and lie to you I
would never lie to you I always tell you
the truth the whole truth nothing but
the truth
harvest the parts build a franca karma
joke Christianity Christian channel
Christian channel bros
yeah how many myself is it more you boy
you're mid-december yeah you can return
your own and get a competent I was only
12 so 12 what are we getting Maps uh I
don't know what about talent points they
exist are we adding more cameras radars
and lied ours
no light ours lighters are stupid we can
go on the lighter is stupid to her
around CES yeah hard what new hundred
we're never gonna tell you in advance
there's gonna be new hardware no company
does that you can't pay for the comment
with your common points you see a
different angle mount will release the
mouse stuff open records car accidents
absolutely every feature you can want no
but level two is a spectrum level two is
a spectrum that ranges from TSS P on the
old Toyota's all the way up to open
pilot 1k a harness isn't included no
that's the brakes folks that's the it's
999 the harness is $200 more can you
recycle the black pan to hardware I mean
you can sell it what about the level for
potential company your tweet it don't
take everything I say seriously navigate
on open pilot yeah and not anytime soon
so I think the Chinese will come with a
knockoff product yeah but it won't be as
good these are actually a lot harder to
build videos because you have to take
the phone apart remove the battery
change the camera we have a custom flex
PCB in the phone that replaces the
battery dashcam integration has a built
in dash cam it's pretty good it's in the
app now it's actually usable now as a
dash cam I can't believe how responsive
Nick and support is to my emails
I'm getting thrown as quick as I can but
the Wi-Fi is slower so I am getting back
to everybody to wear it no I he was
serious his actually I think his cobbler
yeah 13 plus orders any need for faster
CPU or GPU we're still a long ways so
whoa oh the other thing that makes the
comma to better than the ER so remember
with me shipped big model on the e on
and the young kind of crapped out that
was because the eon was hitting its
thermal limits um the comma to has much
higher thermal limits than the eon you
can push that chip a long ways if you
don't have thermal you know we under
clock the cpu to deal with thermal and
on the comet to we can think about about
clocking it again a watt phone it's a
lex
7:20 is it a hundred percent self
driving that's not real brow fit wish
your car was supported me too it's
becoming less and less of a phone now
how can you bring mobile uploads back
maybe maybe I'll think about that what
brand of fan any one of the brand of fan
brother it
in China somewhere on they're really
nice fans though they have they have
they have four wires two for power one
for pulse input and then we have also a
tachometer so unlike the EO and we can
measure you can measure from the
software how fast the fan is turning
will never be better than autopilot
I wouldn't wouldn't say that harness for
GM we don't have it yet future RGB sub
or I don't know what that means you're
brand new explain it to me like a
five-year-old buy one of these read the
website benefits of the firmware what
firmware traffic light detection and I
don't know what I have GGT means if this
than that Oh if savings kill people
future external cameras no Mazda support
maybe no more cameras fan is dead silent
will you Jellico sony car not for me
ship to malaysia yes we ship worldwide
open pile the smoother for me than
autopilot see that's what I'm saying
don't count us out of the combi to has
no battery and no mobile uploads
oh no no so just because it has no
battery it connects into your car gets
constant power from your car yawns are
still young its own story
yeah you notes are still available to
store same price nothing changed
can you just connect the Prius TSU you
can you're going to need to enable
that's the community feature and be
aware that does disable your autonomous
emergency braking will I sell to test
the for 10 billion yeah absolutely you
only give you ten billion dollars I'd do
anything for not anything but yeah 10
billion 10 billion is the price where
you know you just say yes but smaller
amounts of money you gotta have
integrity right for small about some
money have integrity for 10 billion say
yes
can you send a fake email that you're
replacing Yun for free for my wife we're
on it see how this is a Christian
channel I do find that humorous though
is it based on a OSP could I root it
yeah this stuff to build the androids
all over the source you can change it
it's already routed you can SSH into it
if you have come upon you can SSH into
it from anywhere what car should I buy I
want to Priya
that's a pretty good choice I check out
go-to compatible cars on the website the
Corollas bet at our choice I'm gonna
torque mounted civics real nice
no no no it's I'm making fun of
PewDiePie with the Christian Channel
thing a lot of track to meet our unicorn
goal I don't know what do you think our
valuation is we don't raise the money
again because we're gonna be profitable
because you guys are gonna buy so many
common tools the EON is missing on the
shop overview page and there's no link
for this is not it's only like the Deaf
shop ok the least of RCA will put in the
Deaf shop grey panda compatibility so
this is a built-in gray panda this has a
built-in GPS and one of the beautiful
things about this is finally and I know
you guys always ask and it did start to
become a problem the GPS antenna is a
fixed distance from the camera now so we
know if you have a comet - exactly where
your my antennas replaced with respect
to your camera which is really nice
can you get a special edition comic - we
weren't thinking about making green ones
in honor of the Fallen comma one future
Kia Hyundai Genesis they should be how
do you hook it up to your 17 volts yeah
I don't know how people are doing the
volts to be honest this is the black
velvet - comes an L color any color you
want except if you want something that's
not black because it's only black so you
should buy one cyber security
innovations I don't know what that means
free t-shirt with otter no free t-shirts
I'm sorry about that
oh yeah I like that yeah we'll do a
hoodie at a random order or two hoodies
random order yeah that sounds nice yeah
cuz we never have to do it cuz nobody
old no no I will make sure to actually
do it I would lie to you guys
Christian channel post if you're the one
who gets it that's right hoodies are
real volt is very hard now good luck
roll the die for hoodie we will roll the
die it's really printed but the 3d
printing is becoming nice yeah yeah
tell them Alex we shop today by one
someone will get a hoodie up by today
get Rd will tweet that civics better the
Prius and turns the steering motor go 12
I get a hoodie a DM for right now drive
country it's a software issue it's
actually already in read the code and
monitoring D you can just comment it out
it should work
yeah just bought one year that's what
I'm talking about
voltage super reliable a seven point one
will come out
so these ship on the 20th and we have to
ship 7.1 beforehand
resellers yeah if you want to so what we
do for resellers is we have bulk water
pricing so if you want to buy like 10
comma 2 is contact us will give you a
good price if you create a customer on
board its bootloader unlocks yeah
absolutely everything is unlocked what
else we got what else we got oh man I'm
losing my voice - I've had a cold it
took to day quills this morning really
dries you out I don't want to slice of
pizza so bad right now thank you can you
make harness inside yon - it's difficult
to fit it that's problem oh you got me
on chicken where Oh sick I'm gonna eat
orange chicken on streem mukbang mukbang
virtually Chris yeah those are some good
installation videos virtually Chris made
the installation videos orange chicken
oh this is the most conference e food
I've ever seen take a look at that oh
yeah conference salmon Oh food
it wobbles much less with big mouth
it's put free driving to once one window
comes out what's it convert leak where's
a free one
virtually Chris has had a comma two for
a while oh yeah I love you eating
bye-bye simulators good comment powers
required on all pars yeah thank you
thank you
[Music]
oh yeah yeah we're gonna get we got one
fast super combo model super combo model
in 0-7 one lane change in 0-7 one
exclusive on the comet - and also the
Aeon a shout out to virtually Chris or
make me comma to videos super impressed
[Music]
wait
200 miles wat no no we're not giving
away free comma 200 you can make a video
but we love videos but the old freak
llama twos does it exit in change my
ways no no don't change highways if
that's the roads
no freak sama twos no pre common tools
but we will give a free hoodie to one
person who are expecting
how much you make from a firm we lose a
little bit on it four percent what is
the comma to happen to be with the
hoodie any plans for automatic lane
changes yeah you'll see it I mean it's
not automatic its assistant yes it comes
to a complete stop in poopy traffic and
resumes depending on your car but most
of them yes one of the orders Wow 20
orders 20 and will BMW get from a I I
guessed 54
hmm if they buy a hoodie do they get a
free comma - no
well the cg6 mistake it was a mistake we
learned a lot from that we little often
super goofs
eating the stream people are dropping
off they don't wanna see me eat how do
you determine speed from video wouldn't
you like to know when will we move aqua
highway Moe I'm not sure I think there
are bloated organizations will buy the
Yandex team know what AOSP is
open-source all our Android is open
source as well
any details on
No
I'm do this beautiful box
I don't know about the machspeed oh yeah
Alex did the box
custom fold
go around CS boots and Joe's big TVs
Tyler will do a seat yesterday but now
right now I'm tired and I'm hungry a CES
dream later absolutely yo you know
what's here that's crazy
life-sized drones
alex is half as crazy nice Alex wanted
more comments from you guys on the on
the stream breven says I have this busy
just walk please include hoody in order
six-four six-five where's Andy Andy's in
Boston
vendors are fingerprinting problem is
supported on comma two and black Panda
and will be coming soon
I think it's a lot better than stocking
ACCC who's on your board me and that's
that
never give up control your company's
kids because they'll sell them out to
Wall Street I'm eating chicken pie from
America should you get black pan if you
got to come to know if you get a come
through you don't need to buy Fanta it
built in its built-in there's a panda
built in their custom engineer great
engineering well dealerships offer
dealerships are welcome to we have a
great discount November of last year 30
days is the policy 30 days is the policy
I mean does Apple let you return if you
bought the previous iPhone before the
new iPhone comes out he loved till your
customer demographics I don't know them
just Bartlett's girl it's what I like to
hear
guys stop being so cheap you know what
guys I'm gonna be honest with you if the
comma - doesn't make this company
profitable no more climbing AI so y'all
gotta buy them no pressure
I wouldn't do that but that's true but
you know I wouldn't do that that's just
how I feel it's good America's
profitable though if we sell the same
number of eons that we're selling comma
twos I mean if you would buy neon why
would you not buy a comma - it's
literally the eon but with all the bugs
vexed it seriously 1.0 hard right yeah
i'm very happy with that
this is a good product thank you
Alex wants me to remind you we're
shipping on the 20th of January I'll get
your order and soon because if you
missed the first 300 it might be a
little bit before your ships you just
bought it 400 all black pant what so
it's really only $200 like 200 is the
harness you can reuse the harness from
the black pant app to the EON dual comma
- I mean when not looking for UX
designers were open pilot engineer
research engineer how long have we been
testing it um a couple months now I
think we started and we got the first
ones in November
you got season with your order now you
have to wait longer for shipping you're
not sleeping while driving how much can
you earning Commission's we don't have
independent sales reps we don't have
commissions if you want to do that you
want to buy 10 I think we give you like
15% off if you buy 10 so by 10 cell I'm
we're in that 15% infrastructure DevOps
sre that might be the open pilot role um
if you're interested of law request.open
pilot last six months bought it yon
white panda black man and actually you
can justify buying 2 it's not for
everybody it's not for everybody
look the Aeons gonna eat all of open
fire on 0.7 you're still gonna get I
think you'll get 0.8 as well you
probably even get 0.9 1.0 is probably
only for the comet tail how did press go
pretty well
yo we were driving this morning and the
only just engagement we had on the route
was an accident that happened right in
front of us I know like this guy just
like zipped across two lanes and
actually the thing probably would have
done the right thing but I didn't want
to find out comment to will support one
point out yes
the the pharma 2 will definitely support
open pilot 1.0 tell you what
yeah Alex what you want to tell them you
want to hold em so I can eat for a
minute yeah we're happy to do press tell
your favorite YouTube streamers and tech
reviewers but they should review the
comma two about that we might have room
for another demo while we're here so let
us know Chris Andrews furiously freakin
built the website Nick's been amazing
building the comma twos it's got a lot
of time building to cover too so
hopefully everybody likes it we're gonna
post a post a picture on Twitter so you
can see all 300 of them sitting in the
office they were amazing team has been
working around the clock to build the
comma twos
I'm very excited to share them with you
guys there they look amazing in the car
yeah if you bought within the last 30
days just send us an email
Frank not here Gregor Georgie your order
I know we missed you hi Greg
Morgan George
Oh Bobby jerky so monkey man loves rice
all right we have 382 viewers anyone
have any questions send one to Linus
tweet at him where does one get a black
panda the black pendant is on the comic
the car harness page
well panda be upgraded with EP 32 ever
how many hours in workday it's been
non-stop 1260 when is George talk George
talks all the time we're gonna do some
more live streams from the floor George
will take you guys around and show you a
show you see us you can see we're back
here at booth 25 20 if you're in Vegas
come by I'm trying to convince George to
maybe drop some comma twos off on the
drive home
no the software is not ready I'm a tube
in zero seven one they'll be out by the
time
we're just on the 20th show us a
full-size Android any plans stopper
money no there's a second market for
these if you want to sell your comment
beyond and buy a comment to you even
Apple partners with somebody but it
drain us maybe somebody should buy up
all the Youngs for cheaper and then they
didn't resell them in like Africa where
nobody knows about the combat Oh any
other questions
thanks guys just 374 people still
watching it have any questions for the
team was zero seven one leak them one
you guys talk about what happened did
you talk about someone they know about
the super combo any other questions
what cars for the demo specific and the
case before you know it can be with its
model that combines all the sub modules
that we have in the past together so we
have you have the driving model the
calibration model all combined into one
and yeah it's more powerful model you
like it
B&W support it's it's on flex racer it's
not linear
all your day we're thinking about you
your honor names
the same way ynw Melly had murder on his
mind
oh that's the point where four kids kids
friendly comma twos are for everybody
with the driver's license so now our
epilogue at CES no I sure hope they
didn't spend their seedinvest money on
that is they're playing for new merge
drop Alex you guys you buy out all these
if you buy all the comma twos we'll get
new merch I think that's a good China
yeah we can sell 300 of these Oh high
five thousand first first go
Hyundai Kona eBay let's say no might be
support for this end of life of Tamil
one well comma one never existed so
never yeah 2016 was the end of life
what is the temp limitations on the
stock Aeon don't get it too hot it's
happy when people are happy no discord
that samba da di you should go check it
out let his end of life app and any on
soap and any on are no longer you wanna
do what I have to do it who wants to do
the recap
[Music]
business connections its back town
they make LTE modem
[Music]
just tuned in alright we want to recap
go to comma dot AI and lead the website
okay recap
oh my recap is cheap yes yes you can use
your currently installed harness for the
comment too much to say oh the comma
business card yeah you'll remember it
bro
just take a comma and just think a I go
the new mounts a my a celebrity I am
famous people have said that about me
yes look at these big GoPro quick recap
all right so we're kind of a I we
developed software called
open pilot open I can't say driving are
controlling your car in limited
scenarios with a lot of legal
disclaimers but it's actually really
good
our slogans make driving chill if you
want to make driving show you can buy a
comment to this to come into this is our
new hardware it's beautiful
it's got a big screen a big beautiful
screen it's got an infrared camera which
is watching you
you can junction with these IR LEDs to
make sure you pay attention it's got a
custom engineered fan and heatsink
solution they buy some company in China
but it's really good it's got four wires
so we can measure the fan speed dead
silent can't hear it and it has a built
in panda has a built in black panda act
like it's black because the case is
black built in black pants called the
Muto stuff for cancer and tears
it's got battery replacement circuitry
and unless an antenna right here in the
mountains
thirty hours of no Drive in the up oh
it's designed to living it's designed to
live in your car when radar control
sensitivity be reduced yeah we'll fix
that there's that one we already fixed
that internally anything else any other
questions people renaming uno dos for
historical reasons it's the uno although
that would make a lot of sense we're not
working on flex ray you can't get a free
comet oh what's the focus of 2020
end-to-end longitudinal and stability
stability stability stability and growth
and profitability so make sure to buy
them you recently bought an eon if it's
hundred thirty days you can return it
just a package it all back up nicely
send everything back we'll give you your
money back and I think by comments you
get a better 3d printer these are pretty
nice I think you're gonna like we think
you're gonna like them we've so we did a
bunch of things to improve our 3d
printers we put them in a big enclosure
alternative uses for old yawns yawns
make great door stops of yawns make
great gifts for your cousin's who you
kind of feel like this about eons can be
taken apart and used as a 2016 era
smartphone well I'm really I'm really
savage on the Aeons down wow yeah it's
best pretty savage like if I was like a
real company and someone gave me like
like a vise about how I'm supposed to
talking through the are things I'd never
say that like honestly I don't know why
you'd wanted the old bike of a joke
does it have wireless charging no it
doesn't battery oh well yeah three three
months of comma Prime the included
that's a $72 value what do you get what
you get with coming from a lot of good
stuff you get one year of drive storage
you get remote access to your car
anywhere you can if I had my phone in my
pocket I could show you we can take
pictures of the cars anywhere that's a
great new comic run since you're talking
to check your battery voltage watch your
dog I'm a prime shovel yeah if you want
to purchase common prime how do you do
that you already have your credit card
on file because that's how you activate
we're just gonna automatically bill you
connect app download the cover connect
app right now so the Play Store it's on
the App Store it's common five available
in Canada only without a SIM cards you'd
have to get your own is it legal in
North Korea don't have to ask Kim Jong
would kind of connect to GM you'll have
to ask B tasarov's he's still around
maybe Kim Jong you know comma to is an
appreciating asset absolutely no this is
the introductory price you guys know
when I say prices only go up I don't lie
do we ship to Europe yes we ship
worldwide $30 flat rate you're
responsible for all custom fees because
I'm not your government got done and
passed those fees what type of
smartphone is use don't worry about that
you'll never think of it as a smartphone
it's fairly costume yeah USB to obd2 buy
a panda old scoop and a white one North
Koreans called combi - yeah alright go
use the same artist video absolutely
yeah it's the same artist in the black
panda so if you already bought a black
panda it's half of that money you can
just reuse and save that on the compa -
if you can't come to monitoring phone
once it's parked what do you mean by
monitor you can get pictures on your
phone to come on out
boss long you got to do it yourself can
I install the Aeons in Europe for free
yeah I don't control you you can do
whatever you want for free for whatever
price your device your device you do you
want for it Brazil yeah how fast we ship
out everything else is gonna ship on the
13th is how much is you're gonna ship on
the 20th it's more advanced to the
galaxy s 11 I don't know about that in
the commentary yodel wall drive it I
think that's a good end of question
question Donna will give him a few more
minutes out you seem like you're in the
right look we still have like three
hundred forty two people here we can't
let him down guys if all 342 are you
bought Gotama twos right now did I try
the Honda bond we've had pong or they
like your rings common crime is not
available in Europe it is but you have
to get your own SIM card this is a kid
to twitch my Michelle like it really is
I show for all things prime does it have
a JTAG court know how many have been
sold a lot why is Alex in a rush b8 at
the Aria buffet last night
I stuffed my face at the Aria buffet
last night I was pushing like my stomach
was out to here guys not even
exaggerating I think it is too but costs
like 50 more dollars the only the Aria
buffet had oysters I was happy with the
oysters the sushi was really bad the
pokeball was good
what fresh tried it we did Roadshow and
Venture Beat this morning
what hotel we're staying at we got a
condo we got the Vegas Office of comedy
night the new bottle of fantastic thank
you thank you
comment or mobile I trifocal will
consider you can't buy a bubble I try
focus globe liens windows Tesla's Apple
and we are I lost money gambling last
night we're not going to talk about but
Nick made money and now it's made money
so everybody made money oh I bet the
don't pass line it's the best odds in
the casino and the table hates be if the
EON in common to have the same hardware
why are they gonna be phased out before
the combat you if you have to be on with
a black panda it won't be if you haven't
gone with a white panda the problem is
you don't have the the GPS the thermal
solution in the combi to is also a lot
better 0-8 probably will be supported I
make no promises about the future the
only thing I will say is that the combi
2 will definitely support version 1.0
can I switch the camera
yeah but they like all right we're gonna
step back
[Music]
community videos you guys have good
videos post them on the Gaspar video
channel you have a few days famous teams
just working
SiC church in new closet so many
supported cars right now Dori we didn't
forget you community maintains butters
what's expected 1.0 stability stability
stability to be the developer harness
for Kia right now yes and if every one
of them was bought a comment about every
three hundred forty four thousand
dollars we could buy a house oh one more
reminder about a firm oh yeah if you
guys are like wow that's a really high
high price you should feel like a good
American and spend to be in debt with a
firm look don't get in debt you guys I
trust you're smart enough to make your
own decisions we did offer a firm we do
offer a firm if you'd like to buy with a
firm you can pay monthly yeah but I feel
bad shilling for this does not want
people spending and dad as a charge so
you got me in debt for your [ __ ] that's
your choice Ben you gotta make your own
choices
that's about freedom that's about being
an adult I need to start shelling for
Defense College hands just purchase
common without a harness no if you
already have the old harness it's
exactly the same
um this is it appreciating asset I
wouldn't really focus on it as an
investment but we do raise the prices so
like if your choices like if you're
gonna buy it I'm thinking you're gonna
sell it for more later yeah probably not
but if you're gonna buy it now because
you know it's gonna cost more money
later yeah that's a good idea because
it's gonna cost more money back for
those of us have any late can you have a
recap this is a comma to so over there
you should buy one at our website comedy
Johnny I know check out our new website
got a new website we have install videos
it's all easy Fatlip in
what my god some point one song storming
through the party like my name is on the
bedtime in Europe all right would I host
test drives if you're famous or you have
a large outlet is the driver cam
customer off-the-shelf its custom we
have them made at a camera Factory in
China young with white panda will get
dropped soon yeah
gray panda a little bit longer I think
white pant is gonna get dropped in 0-8
who we ship to localize they're a great
pant is gonna last a little bit longer
black panda + E on should last a long
time the only problem is the driver
monitoring so we're gonna see we're
gonna see if this becomes a problem you
know a few people have fallen asleep and
we really want to prevent that and
that's one of the reasons we're really
excited about the AH the driver
monitoring operating both day and night
yeah shout out to a Shane Black Manta +
E on what white definitely won't support
him young be made with a remote screen
no remote screen test drive me I'm as
famous as you if you come if you have
like a channel if you like a channel you
want to post something on we could never
do it we were for supper updates I can't
force anything on you ah what does open
pilot what we lose something connect to
internet time we know it's gonna be 30
days I know you guys can complain what
does open pilot have the autopilot
doesn't what is Linux have that Mac OS
to us and don't compare us to that
compare us to OS 2 which is what all the
other cars are running Co no electric if
you make it support that I don't know
anything about Iran driver monitor yes
very important very important
you dumped Tesla autopilot what does
that mean how do you test about it isn't
it just like you're talking about spring
you chose to share this heavy frame
oh we don't have any you know I did
measure the comma - it's a sex awesome
it's six and a half basically inches
wide it's the same size except the
stupid mount isn't up here it's back
here it's a stealth mount the mounts
completely invisible when you see in the
car it's great in the car yeah do we
ship to Iran I don't know we learned
that we can't ship wide ours I don't
think we ship to our round sorry no we
can ship lied ours but I don't think we
ship - I'm sorry about that insurance
companies offering a discount for usage
but they don't seem to be upset if you
are using it so that's good
how do you get driving data people don't
know opt-in to prime Wi-Fi
I see more tired than usual I'm sick
guys I've had a cold for the last week
prerequisite to install a on a brain
fitness fitness stack that's what I'm
talking about by comma twos oh you will
love large GoPro the new standard large
GoPro it's great on your windshield you
love your black man except if you love
your black pan to set up keep it if you
can want to keep your existing insurance
provider keep it and I mean it we
shipped Africa sure unless you're like
on one of the like export control
countries they do somewhere nice like
Ethiopia will ship to you yeah we got
custom cover drops suits
shut the back sure it's gonna mop their
jumps
FES you will need to delete tesla
Tesla's not our competition our
competition is legacy automakers sorry
why it's coming so it's a lot faster now
cue logs and cucumbers making a lot
faster it's common insurance coming
insurance is boring guys I woke up one
day and I'm like George do you really
want to make an insurance company and
the answer was no oh there's no switches
there's no switches on the harness and
there's definitely no switches on the
comet tail Elon shouted us out mood
I'm how its functionality different
offline versus online offline you get
updates you get dashcam being sent back
to the cloud one year of storage now if
you have come a prime stealth murdered a
stealth mount that's right
one woman localized reproof 0-8 I know
the bitrate slow that's the trade-off
you want fast or do you want quality
let's pick three jumpsuit in order 300
yeah if 300 still happens it comes
around again what is the comment still
one plus it's based on a leaky Cola pro
3 but it's fairly custom to help like
open the phone up we take the battery
out should we replace the camera can you
get a broken Tama for research you can
buy a comma and then break it and then
you can do research on it yeah
they all work you want quality well you
can get quality just probably explore
any I fired the exploring cabana guys
and wasn't getting past our so it's
never gonna get better now is open
source wide replace the camera because
it's infrared it can see in the dark at
night just like in that Paramore song
about castles even in the dark as IR
yeah driver motoring is you can't turn
it off anymore we've turned that off a
while ago could you ever do Hardware
swapping no come on were a small company
guys what you think I'm dealing with
that you think I'm dealing with like
seventeen miss shape and packages that
we're gonna like put some come on what
do I think about all the MLA six I think
they're overhyped
it's only the front camera place you had
a back camera saying ah he's BMW five no
we'll use something like that in the
comma three comma two just came out
we're not even thinking about future
products yet when it's gonna happen what
if pre-orders get personal voicing for
me will shout you out if you buy it
right now am I gonna be the AVN's
if someone invites me absolutely up down
let's do it the self-driving work
offline yeah you don't need internet
connections you don't need the internet
connected to engage it has a check you
have to connect every thirty days it
used to be seven but it's not a big deal
it totally works offline gonna have to
compile commentary
in the 2020 Civic Nebraskan how good it
is
let me dance really good nah to go to
DEFCON anymore boys more chips in the
comments the Snapdragon 820 one what
phone is it inside it's based on parts
of a lake oh all right I was just in New
York and that's why I got sick what are
the main goals 420 end-to-end
longitudinal canceling your own order
just reach in to support will cancel it
feel free to place a comma - you know
what's with the Sony lanyard sony has
too much money and they waited on that
you need to partner with a rental car
company and my partner with anybody
rental car companies to up the bottom
and put them in the car what's new the
comma - its brand new it came out today
go buy one are you gonna look at the
adding voice control cool
you won't comment 3 well you're gonna
have to wait till at least a while it's
porn until the Nvidia Jetson
even try it's what's better about this
one it's free the website we can't just
keep doing recaps
it's gonna get weird it's gonna some
people have been here a long time they
want new fresh original content all over
zum supported bro if I knew things like
that off the top of my head no we're not
level four we're level - we're proud
level - proud level - proud levels - why
such a slow chip chips plenty fast guys
my tech civics stuff is so slow to
accelerate if you need car it's pretty
fast what's your email George at comedy
I will your wheelchair support it that's
why it's open-source your PIN tweet is
so car horn so we got to change that oh
we got to change up in three days
oh nice to come already cell ly dollars
on eBay no we haven't sold them yet
Volvo's in our booth right now maybe
they wanna buy some rely dogs um where
did Sony scan currently in the TV market
I don't know everyone in the live stream
I like that recap the recaps all right
yeah so they were recaps what's the
longest trip made without interruptions
who knows we can check in our data I
think it's probably something like four
hours might even be longer at least if
you poured the car odors in the last 30
days can you get a 200 hour refund
well if you ordered anything within the
last 30 days you can send it back we
were gone over the holiday it hasn't
even shipped it hasn't shipped our lines
are better
Harlan's better the supercargo model why
is there a weather vane behind these
they make weather it
wait what happened oh yeah yeah yeah and
they're like how do you doing this how
good do they want to buy some data
I'll sew up database I'll sell your data
guys we should have like yeah we didn't
but that
will sell you you want to buy some data
are we still honoring yon warranties
yeah the TVs are not playing for Cabana
I know what's a release date for the
comma 3 yo that's like comma two
misspelled it that's like saying like yo
but I want the iPhone 12 where's the
iPhone 12 coming out I bought an iPhone
11 you should buy a comma - alright
okay I think that's the stream guys
thank you all for being with us on this
incredible journey where you're here and
you should buy stuff so we can continue
this incredible journey by comma twos
tell your friends to buy comma tuesd
you're gonna love it it's really a great
product if you could download a comma -
we would love to make that possible
linking you pre-order you can order
right now it's not really a pre-order it
ships on xx if you're in within the
first 300 we already have the made we
just need to do some final tests on them
want to make sure that your comma -
works great we're putting them through a
big QA thing I did not go calm I'm still
right here thank you all for joining how
many sold we're gonna keep that a secret
from here on out but I will say it's at
least 20 if you want to invest in the
company you can't because it's private
you can blame the SEC I would love to
make it possible but all plug me is to
follow me on instagram at george hotz
that's right that's right
keep up the great work thank you thank
you very much
he's nice having you all here today and
you'll see us from seat yes we don't
match it cuz you don't even maps you
just need eyes alright okay